la résidence des remparts
après la départementalisation la mise en
place des nouveaux services
administratifs et l'essor économique qui
débute à la fin des années 1950 attire
de nouveaux migrants venus de métropole
pour les loger un nouveau type d'habitat
apparaît l'immeuble de logements
collectifs symbole d'un nouvel art de
vivre
situé en plein centre ville la résidence
des remparts et le second immeuble
construit à saint denis évoquant les
immeubles collectifs de le corbusier
elle doit faire partie d'une vaste
opération d'urbanisme prévu dans ce
quartier
dessiné par l'architecte jean bossu et
livrés en 1954 elle sera finalement le
seul immeuble réaliser la façade
principale et d'une grande rigueur
géométrique l'architecte ayant dessiné
une trame caractéristiques de ces
premières constructions à la réunion le
programme comporte des bureaux au
rez-de-chaussée et 36 logements de 2 et
4 pièces réparties sur six niveaux les
deux entrées sont marqués par
d'audacieux au vent en béton on y accède
par an oll au centre duquel se trouve un
escalier très original et les deux
premiers ascenseurs installés dans l'ide
chaque étage comporte de f2 et f3 les
plus grands dispose à l'arrière d'une
chambre de bonne desservi par un
escalier de service leur orientation
nord-sud propice à une ventilation
naturelle fut aussi l'un des arguments
de vente de ces appartements alors en
rupture totale avec le mode d'habitat
traditionnel